I believe her and by her I mean Rachel
Mitchell the Judiciary Committee
prosecutor who questioned Christine Ford
and says Ford's testimony is not worthy
of belief we will analyze Mitchell's
letter right here on the hearings then
Kanye makes Saturday Night Live great
again and Jeff Flake somehow manages to
degrade himself even further I knew you
didn't think was possible
president Trump fulfills yet another
major campaign promise that everyone
said was impossible
laia waffle is warns Republican opponent
Jeff Diehl stops by hoping to raise heat
big wampum for his race against against
spreading bull and then we'll go over
the secrets to a long life and shall as
never or dies I'm Michael Knowles and
this is the Michael Nolt show
[Music]
oh so much to go over today we get to
believe her we get to believe her but
the Democrats don't believe her
but we'll talk about why we have to
believe all believable women but first
let's - oh let's talk about battle box
this is very important this is very
important fellas I'm speaking look I
mean this could be gender neutral but I
think I'm mostly talking to the fellas
here most subscription boxes are full of
samples that you'll never use not battle
box it's a monthly subscription box for
men okay I'll say it I'll say it I know
I don't sound like a seventh wave
feminist here but it's four minutes full
of solid gear for adventure seekers
survivalists and outdoor enthusiasts it
is super cool monthly subscription for
handpick outdoor survival everyday carry
around gear it is so good when they sent
it to us the a one of the things that
comes with is just like several giant
awesome knives and hatchets and things
so obviously drew got a box I got a box
and then we just started chasing each
other around trying to like jab at each
other with it but fortunately we all had
knives to fend them off don't try that
at home go to try battle box.com be a
TTL bo XCOM no e slash Knolls canna wles
pick the box you want they start at just
25 bucks per month they are so cool they
have all other sorts of stuff too like
sleeping bags stuff and camping stuff
and make a coffee I don't know I'm not a
big survivalist type guy but now that I
saw the cool knives I am I'm completely
in they've shipped over half a million
boxes they won best men's subscription
box of 2017 it's a great gift for guys
and if you're a guy it's a great gift
for yourself treat yourself right now
our listeners get a free tactical knife
when you sign up for your first battle
box try battle box comm slash noble
Skinner wles try battle box be a TTL bo
x.com
slash Noel's canna wles get your free
battle box + or get your first battle
box plus the free tactical knife at
tribe battle box comm slash Knolls okay
we are in battle aren't we we're in the
heat of battle right now and we have got
we've got to believe her we've got to
believe Rachel Mitchell this is so
beautiful you remember during the
hearings none of the guys on the panel
wanted to be the ones asking questions
of Kristy
Ford because whatever they asked her
would be twisted and and they would be
made out to be misogynists and sexist
and whatever so actually whenever the
panel did speak to Christine Ford they
varied questions between can I give you
a foot massage to what kind of tea would
you like me to make for you it was so
pathetic chuck grassley everything you
want whatever you it so go well I might
want a little coffee tea hehe Oh
whatever okobu so they hired this
prosecutor Rachel Mitchell to ask her
the pointed questions because she was a
woman and she sort of was nice and so
okay they had her do it so we watched
the testimony and Democrats said that
Ford was very credible some Republicans
even said that Ford was credible though
I did not say that Ford was credible
because her testimony wasn't credible
and Rachel Mitchell now agrees with us
she sent out a memorandum we have it
right here I'll just give you the
highlights in case you haven't had a
chance to read it though I do recommend
reading it because it's very good
so Rachel Mitchell admits in the
beginning of it she says while I am a
registered Republican I'm not a
political or partisan person so she
comes right out she says look I am a
registered Republican I've never said
you know I've never seen Rachel Mitchell
on the campaign trail I don't see her at
Tea Party rallies or anything like that
but she says okay I'm putting that out
there right now then she goes on she
says in the legal context here is my
bottom line he said she said case is
incredibly difficult to prove but this
case is even weaker than that doctor
Ford identified other witnesses to the
event and those witnesses either refuted
her allegations or failed to corroborate
them for the reasons discussed below I
do not think that a reasonable
prosecutor would bring this case based
on the evidence before the committee nor
do I believe that this evidence is
sufficient to satisfy the preponderance
of the evidence standard this is what we
have all been saying for this entire
time isn't it we've been saying there
are holes here it seems weak it doesn't
even seem like it reaches the threshold
where we should take it seriously
so she goes on for pages and pages here
are just a few of the highlights doctor
Ford has not offered a consistent
account of when the alleged assault
happened
she hasn't she said into the Washington
Post she said it was the mid 80s to
Dianne Feinstein she said it was the
early 80s then in the polygraph she said
it had
one highschool summer in the early 80s
but then before she fully did the
polygraph she crossed out the word early
shouldn't give an explanation as to why
then she was 15 and she was sixth who
knows who knows when when this was was
she in her early teens was she in her
late teens
she told the committee she was 15 okay
who knows she the Mitchell goes on dr.
Ford has struggled to identify judge
Kavanagh as the assailant by name she
didn't do it until oh just about five
seconds ago that's a little strange when
speaking with her husband dr. Ford
changed her description of the incident
to become less specific yep dr. Ford has
no memory of key details of the night in
question details that could help
corroborate her account this is really
weird because by all accounts from what
dr. Ford is saying she suffered this
intense assault and they not only what
she describes as some guys groping her
what she then says is I thought they
were gonna rape me I thought they were
going to kill me she said she thought
they were going to kill her I don't know
how that she got there but that's what
she said she said she remembers all of
these where the bed was she went into
the bathroom and then the guys were
talking and but then the music was too
loud so she couldn't hear them talking
but then she could hear them talking
whatever and but then she can't say how
she got there and she can't say who
drove her home by as the crow flies her
house was apparently seven miles away
from where the party was so so someone
drove her home but she didn't remember
who so if she suffered this intense
trauma which she nut and she remembers
those details which she don't remember
how she got home who drove her home
because now she's always changed which
people were there and who was there at
the time or whatever now she says there
was another person she names all the
people there all of whom were few her
account and then she says but there was
one other person who I forget I forget
who I was and I can't describe them and
no one's come forward okay all right
little suspect
she says Mitchell goes on dr. Ford's
account of the alleged assault has not
been corroborated by anyone she
identified as having attended including
her lifelong friend this is the big one
her her lifelong friend Leland Kaiser
the girl who she says was you know she
was there at the party I can understand
why if the men were lying that why they
would lie right they say oh no I didn't
I wasn't there I would didn't see it I
didn't whatever but what
would her lifelong friend Leland Kaiser
have to lie none at all she'd have every
incentive to corroborate Ford's
testimony and instead Leland Kaiser
didn't just say that she wasn't there
that Cavanaugh wasn't there she said I
have never met Brett Kavanaugh in my
life so okay that's a little strange
isn't it doesn't seem to lend a lot of
credibility to Ford said dr. Ford has
not offered a consistent account of the
assault yep
you know initially there were four men
in the room then it was two men in the
room and it was this many at the party
than that many okay her account of who
was at the party has been inconsistent
yep dr. Ford has struggled to recall
important recent events relating to her
allegations and her testimony regarding
recent events raises further questions
about her memory that's exactly right
she doesn't she won't turn over her
therapy notes which are apparently some
evidence for this assault she won't turn
them over to the Judiciary Committee but
she can't recall whether she gave them
to the Washington Post or not so that
was you know eight weeks ago or less
than eight weeks ago she can't recall
that you oh I'm not quite sure she then
says that she thought it was her civic
duty to contact the Senate and the
president as soon as possible that's why
she hastily sent all of this out but
actually she contacted The Washington
Post
so was that her sip before she contacted
any of those people and her congressman
she knew how to contact her congressman
but not her senator that's a little
strange too isn't it and again she won't
provide any of the notes to the
committee finally Mitchell says she
alleges that she struggled academically
in college but she's never made any
similar claim about her last two years
of high school
this brings the timeline into question
and it also brings in the question of
how this caused all these awful things
in her life Christine Ford says that she
can't fly she has a fear of flying
because directly related to this alleged
event because she's afraid of enclosed
spaces and all of this but in in other
testimony she said that she's traveled
around she flew to Washington DC she
flies to the mid-atlantic at least once
a year she's flown to Hawaii French
Polynesia Costa Rica but she couldn't
fly to DC to testify before the
committee pretty strange isn't it
their committee offered to go to
California Christine Ford she just never
heard about that so mad she had never
came up okay and then also she
she said that the alleged assault
contributed to her apparent
psychological issues but she was the
word contributed she doesn't say caused
now I wonder why that is because clearly
clearly the woman has issues for the
question our question is what were they
caused by where do they come from what
specifically are the issues okay
after reading just that just and those
are just the highlights there's a lot
more you should go read the whole thing
we can conclude I think that Christine
Ford's testimony is not worthy of belief
nevertheless the Democrats are doubling
down so they don't believe all women
because they don't believe for a chole
Mitchell but I believe I believe women
who should be believed that's my that's
my hashtag it's not it's it's a little
long it's a little clunky when it comes
out of the mouth but I I definitely
believe Rachael Mitchell it's amazing
too because it's I never said I believe
all women
why would I don't believe well I don't
believe Hillary Clinton no you know if
there are a lot of women I don't believe
I don't believe Tawana Brawley I don't
believe Jackie Coakley I don't believe a
lot of women but Democrats the one who
say we have to believe all women and
then they turn around and pretend
obviously Karen Monahan Juanita
Broderick anyone who's a victim of an
assault or at alleges being the victim
of an assault at the hands of a Democrat
they don't believe them
Karen Montana's medical records it's a
lot better than whatever doctor Ford is
spinning her story this week but I do
believe Rachel Mitchell she she gives a
lot of evidence she goes through it very
methodically I believe it so I'm
convinced less and less by the day that
dr. Ford is telling the truth whether
she's lying I don't know whether she's
crazy I don't know whether she's
mistaken I don't know whether memory
changes over 30 years sure of course it
does but I'm less convinced by the day
and I think America is - I really do I
mean they're gonna wait now with this
FBI investigation they're gonna wait for
more crazies to come out of the woodwork
and say that you know Brett Kavanaugh
abducted them in the late 70s and took
them to you know Planet Zebulon seven or
something but I don't I don't really buy
it I don't think this is playing well
with the American people this is also a
lesson to conservatives because a lot
with this allegation and with other
allegations conservatives are so
desperate to be the
guys because very often it's
conservatives who were talking about
virtue the left virtue signals but the
right talks about virtue itself and they
kind of a shoe the Saul Alinsky
Machiavellian politics in immorality in
politics as a principle so we want to be
the good guys we want to be seen as the
good guys we want to believe people we
want to assume good intentions maybe we
shouldn't maybe we should be a little
more skeptical sometimes because I heard
a lot of people saying a lot of nice
things about Christine Ford even during
the hearings even after it was clear
that her story was changing even after
the political influences were clear even
after it was clear that Feinstein gave
her a lawyer even after all things
started but they kept saying oh well I
don't know she seems like a good person
I don't know maybe she's a good person
maybe she's not but we should maybe be a
little harder edged about these things
so one of the reasons that people took
Christine Ford seriously is that she's a
distinguished professor she's a
professor at Palo Alto college so
clearly she couldn't be a crazy person
because no crazy people ever go into
academia right that never happens so as
if on cue as if on cue this woman on
Twitter who is a distinguished associate
professor at Georgetown University their
words not mine I didn't call her
distinguished that's the title in quotes
she tweeted at this she said quote look
at this chorus of entitled white men
justifying a serial rapists arrogated
entitlement apparently now Cavanaugh is
a serial rapist he went from allegedly
groping a girl at some point whenever to
being a serial rapist just keeping you
up to date the woman goes on all of them
deserve miserable deaths while feminists
laugh as they take their last gasps
bonus we castrate their corpses and feed
them to swine yes I'm not making that up
that is a real tweet from this woman
Christine fair distinguished associate
professor at Georgetown you know how
else you can tell Christine fear is a
serious person she has those parentheses
around her name because there are Nazis
all around us this is something that
unserious people do because two years
ago when the alternative right was a
thing for like five seconds the 20
people in the alternative right there
the racist group they they put
parentheses around their name to
identify themselves as Jewish
so some hysterical people still do that
to this day and she's one of them that's
uh say you know she's super duper
serious uh all nature is but art unknown
today so as we're talking about doctor
for the serious distinguished professor
dr. Ford of Palo Alto college could
never tell a lie
we remember that a lot of professors her
absolutely out of their minds such as
Christine fair wishing death upon all
men and wanting to castrate them and I
mean this is a woman who offensively is
teaching children so we remember that we
know that this is a trope the crazy
professor the loony professor with the
crazy hair head in the clouds spouting a
lot of nonsense but it isn't just an
academia SNL decided to they're gonna
take their shot they're gonna take their
swing at Cavanaugh here it is because it
show it really shows you a page out of
the the left-wing playbook what judge
Cavanaugh are you ready to begin
oh hell yeah let me tell you this I'm
gonna start at an eleven I'm gonna take
it to about a fifteen real quick first
of all I showed this speech to almost no
one really funny isn't it in that really
funny yet cuz he was angry
why was he angry I don't know maybe cuz
they're calling him a rapist with the
could that be why so this is what they
do they go out and they first of all
they come up with this totally
uncorroborated charge that he groped a
girl and then they use that to transform
it into he groped a girl at a party at a
drunken party wants to he's a serial
rapist who ran gang rape circles and and
then they accuse him of this before the
public tried to destroy his reputation
his life a life's worth of integrity a
life's worth of a good reputation his
family all of this and then SNL comes
and goes haha look he got angry what up
oh yeah well okay calm down Brett you
just called him a gang rapists yeah he's
gonna get a little angry you are you
kidding me or you but you take a life's
worth of his there to unquestioned
integrity and then try to rip it apart
yeah he's gonna get a little angry so
that's what SNL does that's the
left-wing playbook the left makes up
absurd slander libel flings it at you
and then judges you for reacting well
you can't react you're not allowed to
only the left can react the left has
been a bunch of hysterical children
since November 12th for a long time but
certainly since November 9th 2016 no and
the pink hats and the genitalia on their
heads and the whatever and then finally
a Republican shows a little emotion and
and tells them that they're being
disgraceful and they say whoa calm down
buddy you're not allowed to react only
we can have emotions towards guys
towards so that was the kind of fake you
know pre-written scripted left-wing
response but then the unscripted
response the not approved by the censors
response came later in the show for
musical guest Kanye West
[Music]
to take the father's at the home and
promote welfare does anybody know about
that that's a democratic plan as so many
times I talked to like a white person
about this and when I say that one in
2020 all my smart friends that you have
a situation where we need to have a
dialogue and not a diatribe and if you
want something to change this happening
la New York writers and rappers
musicians so it's easy to make it seem
like it's so-so
so what side preach preach Konya if that
audio didn't sound great to you it's
because it came from Chris Rock's
snapchat or Instagram or something NBC
didn't air that it's Kanye West onstage
NBC cuts the cameras he's got his
magadhan and heat when he opened up and
he said yet Democrats came took the
father's out of the home got blacks
hooked on welfare that's a Democrat plan
did you know about that I thought I was
certainly living in the matrix at that
point I also you got to remember this
comes around because of was it Scott
Adams Candace Owens friend of the show
Candace Owens I think I know that in the
church you're not supposed to go through
the process of beatification until long
after you're dead you're not some you
know those are the stages to become a
saint I formally proposed Candace Owens
for sainthood I know she was pretty
young still in her 20s I formally
proposed it if Candace Owens I like the
way Candace Owens thinks is responsible
for this clarity from Kanye West a major
pop culture mover she deserves saint de
saint candice she deserves to be Saint
Candace of the Blessed tweets
immediately she has done a wonderful job
and this was terrific and talk about you
know
talk about the mainstream versus the
subversive the mainstream versus the
underground even Kayne West isn't
getting this on TV this is on Chris
Rock's snapchat that he caught it live
Kanye West coming out there and saying
nah this is ridiculous
this is ridiculous and Hollywood in the
mainstream media it sounds like there's
only this one-sided view of things but a
lot of Americans myself Kanye West
included reject it this is a beautiful
thing this is a really really beautiful
thing and it it makes me question a lot
of the public opinion polls and all this
blue wave stuff because every so often
the mainstream media they a little
honesty leaks through and that's what I
think is is going on here so in the
meantime you've got some of Cavanaugh's
a former classmates at Yale coming out
and saying you know Cavanaugh used to
drink a lot at Yale Cavanaugh said he
didn't drink that much but I think he
drank that much that's this is the big
new revelation let me tell you something
I come from the same alma mater as dear
Brett Kavanaugh people at Yale are booze
hounds that's absolutely true but if
Brett Cavanaugh says I didn't drink a
lot at Yale Dec that is a perfectly fair
statement because you can be if you are
a like a total booze hound by regular
standards you're probably middle of the
pack at Yale you might be even a little
like toward the teetotaling end of
things yeah okay I mean and even take
the whole Yale thing out of it yeah the
guy drank a lot in college what kept
breaking breaking news everybody college
kid drank a lot of beer breaking stop
the presses okay and also how pathetic
for this guy's classmates to come out
and say hey I haven't been on TV yet and
I feel that I deserve to be on TV so let
me tell you something I knew a guy who
actually did something with his life 30
years ago 35 years ago and he drank a
lot of beer am I still on TV where's my
powder I need some powder too so I can
be on so I can get seven more seconds of
fame out of my 15 minutes totally
pathetic and that's the best they've got
on him the only the only corroborating
evidence we have for any of these claims
is that maybe Brett Kavanaugh had a
couple extra beers then he remembers
okay all right cool cool guys so that's
what the left is doing that's their big
accusation and look at what they're
resorting to there was a political
cartoon that went out was published all
over the place the cartoon was the title
of it you could see on there was
Cavanaugh's daughter says another prayer
you remember during the testimony
Cavanaugh broke down quite credibly I
will add unlike some uncredible
testimony this was quite credible and
said his ten-year-old daughter said that
they should pray for the woman dr. Ford
so this cartoon comes out it says
Cavanaugh's daughter says another prayer
dear God forgive my angry lying
alcoholic father for sexually assaulting
dr. Ford that's the left for you that's
the left for you America those are
that's the Democrats attacking a
milquetoast federal judges ten-year-old
daughter for praying that's the left and
you know they always go after prayers
the left hates prayers they always
whenever there's a tragedy and decent
people say well I'm praying for you they
say I don't want your prayers how dare
you pray for me because the left
believes that the world is perfectible
that we're gonna stop crime and sadness
and tragedy and violence and suffering
if we just give them a little more money
in a little more government power the
right knows that that isn't possible
we're out of the garden we're we're not
going back to the garden this world is
imperfect and fallen so we say well I'll
pray for you
say I don't want your damn prayers
they're saying the same thing about this
ten-year-old girl now they're attacking
his ten-year-old daughter it's really
despicable they're calling him a sexual
asylum for for totally uncredible
testimony and allegations that came out
at the last minute after the original
hearings were wrapped up that no one had
ever heard about before from this woman
whose story keeps changing okay
really really pathetic so why is all of
this allowed to keep going on oh because
of this star of the hour the man who the
only so he had to take a break
unfortunately because Jeff Flake was
staring at himself in the mirror and
then he took a quick little break to go
on 60 minutes and they went right back
to adoring himself in the mirror here is
Senator Jeff Flake moral
and moral idiot sitting next to Democrat
Chris Coons on 60 minutes have your
moment senator senator flake you've
announced that you're not running for
reelection and I wonder could you have
done this if you were running know your
life no not a chance
not a chance no no because politics has
become too sharp too partisan that
there's no value to reaching across the
aisle
there's no currency for that anymore
there's no incentive the reason that he
couldn't have done this if he were
running for re-election is he would be
accountable to his constituents that's
what he's saying he says oh yeah if I if
I were accountable to my constituents I
couldn't possibly do this pathetic
disgusting cowardly a collaboration with
Democrats to further destroy this good
man's life I could never have gotten
away with that but hahaha I'm not
running for re-election so I'm totally
unaccountable disgusting
so I hope you enjoyed himself on 60
minutes he does love seeing himself on
television so that's very nice for Jeff
Flake but what he did is so cowardly he
he because he's the one he's the guy who
did it he said I will not vote for
Kavanagh unless there's a seventh FBI
investigation into him that will analyze
all of the statements that we already
have from all the people who refute dr.
Ford's testimony why did he capitulate
well who knows he might have been
planning on it the whole time the the
proximate reason the immediate reason is
that he was confronted in an elevator by
a screaming woman and this changed his
mind will tell you about that that
screaming woman we've looked into her
background but here is the here's the
moment that changed Jeff Blake's mind
and turned him into even more of a
coward than he already was young girl
what are you doing sir
what are you doing so that that woman
there are two women they're actually Ana
Maria
our Aquila and Maggie Gallagher they are
too high level George Soros operates
George Soros funded left-wing operatives
sound conspiratorial well sometimes
conspiracies are right they work for and
run the Center for popular democracy
this is a left-wing activist group Soros
and Soros is open society foundation is
one of the three largest funders of that
group it was a total set up a total hack
job and flake fell for it
or maybe he wanted to go along with it
so that he could preen and virtue signal
even more rather than having to go
through the difficult work of actually
displaying virtue it's a lot easier to
virtue a signal than to actually display
virtue so there's some misconceptions
here pushed forward by the the Jeff
Flake line of things well I want to
reach across the aisle and everybody
know just get a fair blah-blah-blah-blah
okay nobody is going to be convinced by
this FBI investigation Democrats have
already said it's worthless because it
doesn't get to go on for months and
months and years and years nobody in the
middle is going to be convinced by this
FBI investigation Cavanaugh has already
had six we've already got testimony from
everybody that could possibly be
involved and the FBI doesn't reach
conclusions so it's completely worthless
all it will do is further inflame
passions it'll leave the Democrats
unmodified and more lunatics we'll have
time to come out of the woodwork and
accuse Cavanaugh of whatever they're
going to accuse them for really pathetic
so we're still talking about Brett
Kavanaugh thanks to Jeff Flake moral
coward moral idiot there is some good
news today though and then I've got to
say goodbye to Facebook and YouTube but
before we do that I want to remind you
that this administration is chug chug
chugging along and making America great
again they've reached a deal on NAFTA
you remember this was a major Trump
campaign promise we're gonna renegotiate
NAFTA the North American Free Trade
Agreement between Canada the United
States and Mexico
they say it's being unfair to Americans
and it's threatening American jobs we're
gonna defend American workers finally
there had been a bipartisan consensus on
NAFTA that it was signed under Bill
Clinton pushed by Newt Gingrich backed
by both Republicans and Democrats and
but there were some losers to NAFTA and
in particular the American worker in
certain segments so Trump made it a
major pillar of his campaign that he was
gonna renegotiate NAFTA for months now
we've heard he's got getting into fights
with
Canada in Mexico and they all hate him
and everybody hates him he can't work
out a deal that's never gonna happen oh
no no no no no they worked at a deal a
little while ago they worked at the deal
with Mexico then Canada was threatening
not to join in Canada joined in they
worked out a deal the stocks the markets
in the United States Canada and Mexico
all trading higher today the S&P is up
0.7% the Dow is up over 250 points the
Canadian dollar and the Mexican peso are
both up so what is in the deal is it
only cosmetic is it a major change there
are some changes in here the deal raises
the threshold for autumn auto production
the automobile production in North
America to qualify for zero tariffs it
raises that threshold from sixty two
point five percent to seventy five
percent that's a pretty significant
increase it says up to 40 percent of
parts for tariff free automobile sales
must come from high wage factories so
that means moving all of production out
of Mexico and not we're no longer gonna
have this huge amount of production in
Mexico some of that will come back to
the US and to Canada now this is not
indexed to inflation so what will the
effect of that be over time maybe it
won't be insane but still that's that's
a really solid concession for the
American worker
i means relief from future auto tariffs
for canada and mexico so the free
traders who say that tariffs don't work
they or mollified here because Trump has
said time and time again I want zero
tariffs but I want there to be actual
free trade and actual fair trade plus
there's a win for American cheese and
wine you know a lot of this the issue
with Canada has centered around Canada
having its own dairy tariffs so you know
this hurts the American dairy industry
Trump said we're not going to permit
that anymore Justin Trudeau said you
know this was a crime against people
anity because humanity isn't that's not
who people who keep her daughter in it
TTD we put door that's kinder that's
nicer he said that was a really bad
thing he was obviously bluffing they
fixed that this is a big win and the
point I'll leave you on with this is
Donald Trump is being excoriated for
making this comment about Kim Jungman
over the weekend he was at a rally on
Saturday and he said quote this is this
is like pretty Trumpy even for president
Trump he said I was
they tough and so is he and we were
going back and forth and then we fell in
love okay
no really he wrote me beautiful letters
and they're great letters we fell in
love he's talking about North Korean
monster Kim jong-un we fell in love why
did he use that diction because it gets
headlines right it grabs people's
attention it gets headlines okay
and because Kim jong-un is is watching
this probably scratching his fat little
head and thinking what the hell is this
president thinking who is this guy that
I'm talking to and so he says we fell in
love okay everyone's own no this is a
travesty oh no no no president Trump
said he was gonna renegotiate our
agreements with NATO everyone lost their
minds what happened NATO allies started
paying more of the bill pour more of the
bill that they were already supposed to
pay he says we're gonna renegotiate
NAFTA everyone says it's gonna plunge
the world into global economy what
happens we renegotiate NAFTA all the
markets increase the US has the
strongest market we've had in a very
long time the economy is doing
extraordinarily well record low
joblessness we've brought North Korea
more to the negotiating table than we
have in a very long time we've worked
out a pretty serious and nuanced
strategy in Syria and the Middle East
certainly more nuanced than we have in
years we've defended our allies in the
Middle East we've hurt our enemies we've
renegotiated foreign aid and aid to the
United Nations maybe just trust this guy
on the negotiations I'm not saying put
your faith in princes I'm just saying at
a certain point your your your outrage
has to run out it's got to become a
little tedious doesn't it if every
moment the world is about to end because
of something that Donald Trump says some
outrageous statement and then it doesn't
and don't you get tired after a while
don't you think maybe he knows what he's
doing maybe he's okay at being the
president maybe it's pretty good at it
actually that's my take on that we fell
in love with Kim jong-un I don't I don't
know what Melania thinks of that we fell
in love maybe this is gonna be the next
Michael avenatti case I've got to say
goodbye to Facebook and YouTube we've
got Jeff deal coming up he is
challenging senator Lyle Wafaa in
Massachusetts and he's gonna tell us a
little bit about the campaign and the
blue wave and the red wave then we've
got the keys to a long life and before
we
go Sharla's navour died one of the great
crooners that nobody knows about but
we'll talk about him all of that if you
go to daily wire comm I'm sorry if
you're on Facebook and YouTube I've got
a second body you go to daily wire comm
you get me the and reclaim each other
ben shapiro show ask questions in the
mailbag that's coming up on thursday ask
questions in the conversation that's
coming up none of that matters this is
what matters the mmm-hmm you know what
that tastes like
that because this is a local brew this
is a local brew from Los Angeles this
tastes like Kavanagh committee Spectator
Alyssa Milano's tears she did you know
Alyssa Milano was there at the earrings
for some reason I don't know why she was
probably just there I guess I don't know
if I'm telling tales out of school from
the daily wire we we sent her we we
invested in this because we knew that if
she were sitting there in front of brick
Avenue she would work up the most
delicious only only the most beautiful
leftist tears that we could fill into
our tumbler and provide to you all
that's just 100 dollars for an annual
membership go to daily wire comm we'll
be right back
we've got Jeff Neal Massachusetts State
Representative he's challenging Liz
Warren senator Lyle Wafaa
chief spreading bull he's hopefully to
raise some heat big wampum for his race
don't forget a Republican held that seat
in very recent memory it could happen
again and everyone's calling for a blue
wave but I don't really buy it
especially not in the Senate especially
if we get Kavanagh through here is my
quick interview with Jeff Diehl then
we'll talk about the keys to a long life
representative deal thank you for being
here Michael thank you for having me on
so you are going after one of my
absolute favorite targets in
Massachusetts chiefly OWASA herself
Foca Hondas Elizabeth Warren obviously
there's there was a Republican who had
her seat not too long ago and but she's
snuck in there and she's one of the more
radical members of the US Senate
what are you running on what are you
what are you going after her for and
what do you think your chances are well
first of all Elizabeth Warren's probably
the most divisive voice down in
Washington DC I mean she shows that you
cannot work with Republicans on
everything she tries to politicize every
single thing including you know the the
Kavanagh nomination I mean she's out
there now trying to fundraise off the
the issues going on with the vetting she
called for the 25th amendment a few
weeks ago
there's nothing Elizabeth Warren won't
do to try to divide Americans for her
own personal gain and that's what
Massachusetts citizens are seeing that's
why I won my primary three weeks ago
overwhelmingly they've know that in
Massachusetts I have a track record of
actually cutting taxes I was able to
save over two billion dollars when I led
the repeal of an index gas tax whereas
Elizabeth Warren has delivered nothing
for Massachusetts and now it's clear she
wants to run for the White House and
continue to do nothing for our state I
think people are waking up to that and
we're showing polling that gives us a
lead with independents I think she sees
the same polling because she challenged
me to three debates the night that we
won the primary Wow that is uncommon you
would think she'd want to run away from
debates as the incumbent but maybe she's
she's worried about that I'm from New
York I live in California I understand
the issue of running as a republic
in those states but you've been a
supporter of the president I you you
worked on his campaign in 2016 how do
you think that's gonna play is that or
the midterms gonna be a referendum on
the president what's that going to mean
for blue states that didn't vote for him
in 2016 what what kind of line do you
have to walk in the campaign well just
as a background in 2016
20,000 Democrats unenrolled to vote in
the Republican primary which ultimately
gave Donald Trump 50% of the vote with
13 candidates in the field so if you
think about that it was his largest
margin of victory Chile hit his home
state of New York so the fact of the
matter is people in Massachusetts are
seeing the success of the president
whether it's the economic tax reform of
2017 that's given us in our state this
last fiscal year over a billion dollars
in new revenue based on all the wage
increases plus we have country leading
low unemployment we're at 3.5% I know
the nation is around 3.8 percent we're
doing very well in Massachusetts
Elizabeth Warren wants to undo the tax
reform she's vowed to repeal that and
the other thing that she wants to do is
raise individual taxes so fact of the
matter is economically people in
Massachusetts know that she's not really
going to be good for them and the other
thing too is I think it's clear she
wants to run for the White House she's
been making moves she's been spending
time out of state so this state is
looking for someone who's going to
deliver have a seat at the table in
Washington having supported the
president I'll be able to work with the
White House and a republican-controlled
Senate to deliver for Massachusetts well
I'm hoping that she gets that nomination
for the presidency because she's one of
the wackiest candidates out there and
she's so far left she's so unlikable
she's so divisive and she politicizes
the you know she's politicizing these
Cavanagh hearings to raise heat big
wampum for her campaigns and I really do
hope that that were dance to your
benefit I'm also thrilled that you're
not running away from the White House I
know a lot of times in blue states
Republicans run away from national
Republicans and I think it's always a
mistake I think they it always hurts
them when you don't stand for something
but what do you think that this midterm
election is going to look like we've
been told by the experts that there is
going to be a blue wave across the
country and I don't really buy it
unless we don't confirm Cavanaugh
perhaps I don't really see it happening
where do you think that stands
nationally well to be honest with you
nationally I don't think it's going to
be a blue wave I think it's going to be
blue undertow the fact that they seem to
stand against tax reform that's
benefiting the middle class the fact
that they're against law enforcement
because nationally they stand for
sanctuary city status or sanctuary state
status elizabeth warren's same thing
wants to eliminate ice an agency that's
working to protect the people of my
state the cities the communities by
deporting those who are here illegally
committing crimes she wants to get rid
of ice that those people doing that work
and at the same time she also I don't
know if you remember this when that
college student Molly Tibbets was
murdered by someone who was in the
country illegally and should have been
deported before that murder was even
committed she said the real problem is
family is being separated at the border
she's so out of touch with what is
hurting Americans and in Massachusetts
we have a young man named Matthew Denis
who was killed by an illegal immigrant
who had a track record that should have
had in deported years before he
committed that murder his mother Maureen
Maloney is separated permanently from
her son and that's the families that I
want to try to work towards protecting I
think ice is important to have so
nationally if Democrats keep doing this
of course they're making a big mistake
in Massachusetts that's why I've been
able to get the endorsement of law
enforcement to the point where I even
have the Boston patrolman's Union giving
me their endorsement something that's
very rare for does not happen to
Republicans that's right that's right
well that's a that's a wonderful point
and I do notice on your lapel it looks
like you have a thin blue line flag
lapel at because you've got Democrats
now including Liz Warren in many ways
leading the charge saying I'm not just
opposed to certain immigration policies
or I prefer one law or the other there
they're saying I oppose law enforcement
per se
who cares you little people if you've
passed your laws I don't want any
enforcement of that law because I know
better than you do I can't imagine
look I know Massachusetts is a blue
state but I know a lot of people from
Massachusetts too I can't imagine that
when you're talking to people on the
street
the
they're the sort of people who will say
yeah I hate the cops I don't want any
cops I don't want law enforcement that
just seems to be such an elitist
disconnect there really is a disconnect
and I'll tell you something we've got a
state Senate that tried to in this last
budget cycle insert sanctuary state
status and it was rejected by the
conservative Democrats in our house I
serve in the House of Representatives
here thankfully we were able to reject
that but we also have judges like a Tim
feely in Salem who actually put a heroin
dealer back on the streets based on his
immigration status he actually said
during bench conference that if he had
been American citizen he would have
given him jail time for the heroin he
was dealing but because he was an
immigrant and would have been separated
from his family because he would have
been subject to deportation he decided
not to give him a sentence and so when
you have two sets of laws in
Massachusetts and I think this is with
judges around the country and you have
Elizabeth Warren undercutting law
enforcement and saying we should get rid
of ice you've combined to say that the
Democrat Party nationally and in
Massachusetts no longer cares about the
rule of law that protects the families
of Massachusetts yes that's right and I
followed the race I know you won the
primary solidly so I really appreciate
it I really appreciate your campaign I
hope you do well I hope people listening
and watching will send you lots of money
so that we can repeal you because
somebody like Elizabeth Warren should be
a prime target we know that that
Massachusetts has rejected Democrats
radical Democrats we have particular
policies in the recent era I think she
is get a bull I don't think she's
bulletproof and I wish you the best of
luck I've taken up too much of your time
I know you gotta get back to the trail
but represent a toilet
sorry go ahead thanks Mike no no I
appreciate that yes this is the state
that voted for Scott Brown back in 2010
when he was going to be the 41st vote
against the Affordable Care Act um the
unaffordable Care Act really and but the
state was the model for it so I think
this state is going to vote what's in
their fiscal best interest but if people
want to help they should go to deal for
Senate comm which is di e HL fo r Senate
comm I could use all the help I can get
because Elizabeth Warren certainly is
not just a problem for our state
we're votes also affect everybody in the
car the other reason that people should
donate to you and support your campaign
is because I can't wait for your future
campaign book the art of the deal that
is gonna be a terrific piece of campaign
literature and there's gonna be that'd
be great for the country representative
deal thank you so much for being here
thank you Michael
mr. deal future senator about to hack
away at the at the Liz Warren campaign
at the list Warren incumbency okay we're
obviously a little close but I've got to
get to the most important thing of the
day which is the keys to a long life
because I just found out I was reading
this headline I am gonna live forever
I am the the keys to a long life this
was a headline over the weekend quote
drinking dr. pepper and smoking cigars
centenarians share their secrets to
living past 100 and I love this I I
spoke at Franciscan University of
Steubenville over last week at the end
of last week and we were talking about
the simple joys of being right you can
catch the speech I think it's online I
think we broke it down this the seven
simple joys of being right and one of
them is well I won't ruin the speech all
of them lead-in to us really enjoying
life and so Richard Overton he's 112
years old is the oldest army of that
he's one of the oldest living Americans
I think well the oldest living people he
smokes eighteen cigars a day he drinks
whiskey in his morning coffee his
favorite foods are catfish gravy
macaroni and cheese he still drives us
1970s forward this guy is great he was
in cigar aficionado that's how I first
found out about him
smoking cigars all the time Elizabeth
Sullivan hundred six years old she
drinks a you know Dr Pepper every single
day and she said the doctors keep
telling her that it's poison and it's
going to kill her but they keep dying so
there's got to be a mistake somewhere in
there I really like this because it you
know one aspect of lefty culture right
now is hating death I think they've
always hated death and so these Silicon
Valley types are always trying to find
the cure to death we're going to end
death in this generation we're going to
figure out a way to cure death and we'll
live forever
by the way there is a way to live
forever but we'll get to that
and all the religious questions in the
mailbag on Thursday as so they talk
about that and then all these other
lefties they do the same thing to one
degree or another it's that's what all
of the crazy diets are about veganism
and a GMOs and that and whatever it's
all about trying to squeeze a little bit
more time out of this life a couple more
months a few more years but the the cost
of that is that you can't enjoy life
having a little whiskey smoking cigar is
drinking dr. pepper these are some of
the joys of life if you don't if you
don't do those things what are you
living for one of the aspects when you
stop believing in some fantasy that
you're never going to die on this earth
that you're going to live forever that
we're gonna create utopia when any
aspect of that left wing fantasy vision
when you abandon that when you stop
trying to do something that isn't
possible then you can actually enjoy
life and I'm glad that these
centenarians are all enjoying life and I
hope mr. Overton has a whiskey and a
stogie for me today in the final bit of
news one of the great crooners Sharla's
navour has died he is the French
Armenian crooner they call him the
French Frank Sinatra he was like this
five foot tall Armenian guy I think he
might have been born in France his
father was an immigrant maybe he was an
immigrant and he was just one of the
greats he was so is pretty weird a
little radical but so smooth so charming
very few people in America ever listened
to him anymore but they should so r.i.p
to mr. Aznavour and I will leave you on
this note Sharla's divorce singing you
are the one for me for me table
[Music]
you are the one for me for me daddy you
are my love hurry
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
seniya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by mic core Amina hair
and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael Knowles show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018